it's now I'm a Christian it's now I'm a
Christian you just take it past this
idea and I'm I'm trying to be
open-minded because I'm an open-minded
man a modern man but the idea that a
garment that a religion has forced women
to wear for more than a thousand years
because they're women forcing them to be
modest but I think the job is extreme
but you don't for some reason and I
don't know what's now I'm a Christians
now I'm a Christian you need to turn the
tables around right in persuasion you
need to turn the tables around and show
him some evidence from his own book and
from his own system of thoughts I'm a
Christian because he's seeing that there
is a problem I think a job is extreme
but you don't for some reason and I
don't know why and you know that there
is no problem but if you're always just
explaining then it's like you having
your back to the roles and you need to
turn that situation around so I
introduced the idea of hijab earlier on
the it's it's mentioned in the Bible
that a woman is not authorized to teach
in the church a woman is not authorized
to teach in the church if she wants to
know something she should ask her
husband at home so now this is more than
than any Muslim will say because even
the most conservative Muslim will say
and that in in the Masjid they can be a
class held by a sister and she's
teaching at least other sisters right so
she can be a teaching person to say that
the woman cannot speak in the church
even speak it says so that the the woman
should not speak in the church that she
should remain silent these are specific
stipulations in the Bible one can go to
first Timothy chapter 2 verse number 15
and and and see that these regulations
are are there in the Bible for example
just to name one I'm a Christian I'm a
Christian and so now if to cite them
something like this may be surprising to
them because they never thought of it
before they haven't read the whole Bible
the Bible is a big book much bigger than
the Quran so you know most Muslims have
not read the
run from it from beginning to end and if
they have read the Quran maybe they read
it in Arabic even though they don't
understand the language just for the
barakah the blessings and they don't
know the instructions therein so a lot
of questions may not be familiar with
the details of the Bible and they think
that whatever is the modern Western
society that is what Christianity is and
now they're coming to you and say how
could your Islam be like this they don't
realize that what we are talking about
is common to the world's religions so
decency in society dressing well for
both men and women this is what is
taught by the world's religions the
Bible itself says that women should be
modest and not go with with their hair
decorated and so on wearing decorations
but they should come in a humble and
modest way so basically that's what
we're talking about as well so when you
show them that there is something
comparable in their own scriptures then
that will help them to understand the
point as well by wearing gold or pearls
or expensive clothes for women who plan
to be devoted to God should make
themselves attractive by the good things
they do this church isn't very different
from the churches of today women today
are more focused on their outward beauty
and being pleasing to the yeah but God
doesn't look at outward beauty he knows
what he created good beauty is shown
through action even the most attractive
woman in the world loses all the power
inner beauty when she's vile and goes
around hating everyone and everything
beauty and evil do not go inside when
women are fixing themselves up to look
nice for others spending hours on their
hair deciding what clothes to wear what
jewelry is gonna match are they really
being godly a woman has herself so
attractive that a man other
husband is looking at her with less this
man is committing a sin and if a woman
causes a man to stumble he's not
considered holy or righteous godly the
house should a godly woman conduct
herself I personally believe that her
hair shouldn't be flowing around
beautiful gorgeous for other men to look
at that her skin shouldn't be showing
off that her body shouldn't her figure
should be known her clothes shouldn't
accentuate her curves and I know how
judgmental in the world is ladies but we
are called to be set apart other men
should have no desire to gaze upon us
with less rather their eyes should be
out of respect and yes we can control
this the King James Version reads in
like manner also that women adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
shamefacedness and sobriety not with
broided hair or gold or pearls or costly
array but which becometh women
professing godliness with good works so
two words stand out here shamefacedness
and sobriety JP Smith means a sense of
shame or honor
modesty bashfulness reverence regard for
others and respect abiding means to have
soundness of mind and self-control that
woman should humble herself regard
others think before she speaks and
respect everyone around her a godly
woman does not draw attention to herself
for a godly woman does not want the
attention John on her but on our
wonderful creator this is Mary with
beautiful.you ministries shelah and
goblak Jesus's mother Mary what did she
do she wore hijab Jesus before he was
born that Jesus's mother worshiped him
who was not even brought into this world
yet and then when he was a little baby
was she worshiping him as a guy no she
was worshipping the same God that our
sister now is worshipping Allah Allah
hah and Aramaic the sister language to
Arabic I want people to see the
commonalities and to see the authentic
pure message that Muslims are upon and
you'll see in 1 Corinthians it says that
a woman who prays prophesizes without
her head covered she might as well shave
her head off she does honors her head
it's in the Bible it's there so bits and
pieces of it are there but has been
altered has been changed that's why the
crater sent the Quran tamper free tamper
proof and it is the verbatim word of God
and
final messenger probe Muhammad peace be
upon him and most people who are sincere
truth seekers are seeing this the
message is resonating because it's
straightforward it's simple it's based
on logical proofs and evidence says do
what she suggested you do real simple do
what Jesus did he didn't put no monkey
in the middle he didn't put anyone
between him and God he'd out up the
wreck do that call on the Creator alone
and ask for the guy who's asked for the
Direction asked for the purpose of life
from the one who made you your maker
straightforward simple nothing esoteric
strange here worshiping only one God to
create another creation I keep
mentioning over and over because that's
what Islam is all about and if you can
dig that everything else will fall in
place if you can't even understand that
how we help you understand anything else